[Music]
[Applause]
hello all Minnesota guy remember so you
don't have to but then athlete now being
chosen as the new Dark Knight you have
to wonder if anyone ever gave any
consideration to having been athlete
play a superhero in the panel isn't it
you don't understand this isn't just a
bad comic book movie this is a bad comic
book movie from the early 2000
you know how comic book films are huge
now as smart and funny and clever well
back in the day councils were still kind
of seen as kid stuff and films like
these certainly didn't help his case no
comic book movies back then had to try
even harder to be taken seriously which
surprisingly backfired and how
repetitive babycakes every movie has to
be dyed and gritty and painful which
isn't bad once in a while but with every
single fucking one of them starts to
look like that they start to come across
as Mobe complaining and downright not
fun don't get me wrong so films did it
okay but one like daredevil let's just
say something I'm really not looking
forward to reviewing a wall you will
need you critic I will help you who are
you I am a superhero from the early 2015
Oh that'd be a well that's great I could
use some help reviewing this year once
it comes in next to me thank you but I
must stay here I have so many brooding
poses on top of rooftops to show oh yeah
I guess that was kind of a thing for a
while well we will get through this
together
or my name is Adi alright prepare for
early 2000 super cheese with daredevil
it makes me want to hang my head
constantly as the credits roll blood
drips down a thin glass window of the
Virgin Mary while our hero hangs in pain
off the cross at the top of a church yep
it's that kind of movie kids once you're
throwing God weeping in the corner
saying what the poetic despair has life
become
we don't slash back to the good old days
of the bad old days when we see Affleck
playing Matt Murdock growing up in a
part of town called Hell's Kitchen you
know it's coming so here it is versus
cocks rifle back to the V when he was a
young boy he was always beat up by the
kid from da shit that's a soprano joke -
where's that joke filed under um of
course no why what's wrong um so that's
why you were interrogated in law in
order he's upset because his dad used to
go nine rounds with Henry wait Louis
now he goes nine rounds with heavyweight
heineken you don't hit nothing with
books get me but when he discovers his
dad was working for a crime bot he's not
old odds did some hazardous chemicals
that make him blind you know why is it
anything that can give you superpowers
is not better protected you for life
I'll have it all you want on it but when
kids are allowed in the area and it's
fucking everywhere like goddamn candy
Christ you might want to rethink
security a little bit
I'm sorry money just a gives up his life
of crime but he shouldn't feel too sorry
it's the chemical tighten Murdock's
other senses allowing him to see the
world like every special feature in a
ps3 game hey Murdock Wow
yeah that's right we're such
one-dimensional bullies were actually
gonna beat up a blind kid we kind of
have no soul next we're going to teach
tap dancing to people in wheelchairs
also while beating them up hisses ugh
thing you wouldn't understand
oh no he has attained all I've been
doing since then he respected I guess
he's even become so good that he could
even tell when his father is losing a
fight with the wait a minute
his powers are so good he can hear
punches over a screaming crowd and he
could take on bullies all by himself
oh yes super powers came through then
I'm actually completely deaf you are yes
telephone rings would you make me move
all I hear but it also gave you super
lifting power to plan so there's totally
no point do you being definite yeah if
one thing was taken away from you but
then giving back in a different way
there's totally no point in moving of
course there is it gives me an edge yes
it doesn't if I think you can sense
things better than you could before look
at our hero he doesn't even need this
dick not only is he a better fighter
than most but he's pointing out went
across the street better than mandatory
cameo Ken so the disability is totally
pointless in fact it's almost like you
don't even have a disability
well I also broke my arm did you get it
fixed maybe matter it doesn't impact
anything with your character part of EA
the potential wind ever just push you
off a building yeah yeah so because his
father doesn't throw the fight he's
killed by a bunch of thugs with the
final punch being given by a villain
called the Cape who is a rose with all
his victims because it'll leave no trace
that way
I mean Peter
I mean Simba I mean oh you know what to
do with this um hi audience ah the
director has decided to hold on me for a
bit learn all about it oh thank god
who's getting really awkward I am count
Aflac EULA
I have come to thought and that's it so
rather than oh I don't know hand himself
over to science to help other blind
people that's what he does he decides to
become a lawyer because let's face it
saying that justice is blind phrases
just to something not to use justice is
blind see I've stopped off at Josie's
bar after work how's she doing she asked
me if I would stick around for some fun
yeah
listen to his heartbeat to see if he's
lying it not be so obviously lying tone
he's so obviously lying with miss Sutton
doesn't enjoyed every minute Yeah right
another rapist back on the street this
of course forces him to take justice in
his own hand
[Music]
what's totally necessary that guy's for
real yeah it's real what do you want
okay I'll give you three guesses what
he's going to answer that with one
Direction's back with gay pride parade
to the cosmopolitan maybe oh just a
little bit more cranberry juice than
usual or three just assume a superhero's
answer for anything is justice how are
you justice what are you eating justice
how do I get to your house oh just take
a right on Michigan Avenue off the
corner of Wabash injustice he tracked
him down to its subway where he finally
gets the justice he deserves that light
in the tunnel
let's not happen that's right
daredevil going to kill you because Matt
Murdock is a terrible lawyer to enjoy my
compensation for my terrible
occupational choices determined to get
his half of the story show father Leo no
comes in playing Robert wall - the humor
before he became Robert wall - the humor
and he suspects the urban legend pear
devil might be behind us are you here to
confirm the daredevil is responsible for
this detective there is no proof that
your so-called daredevil was involved
know what that he even exists
got it now let me bask and how easily
and stuck-up I am as I know for a fact
that I win no way be contradicted at all
got it you know that's not exactly the
most obvious or safest calling card say
they didn't see that gasoline on the
floor like most people wouldn't one of
another subway writer was just waiting
for a train while smoking
maybe they're Christian on you're never
there every time you see together and
wake up in the morning alone I thought
that if my wage let me Oh fuckin J hello
will she ever get the message after
Julia's pill because that's what our
core people do he goes to confession as
the priest is apparently the only one
who knows this secret forgive his father
well I've sent for I am making daredevil
your penances 10 years obscurity do one
Argo one Gong girl and maybe one day you
will be Batman I wouldn't say that
katana was singled out by the demonic
vigilante not meet up with his partner
played by John Poirot clearly taking
notes on how not to direct a superhero
movie mr. Lee he made his first payment
he paid in fluke what what where where
where ah yes so chemicals also gave him
super sniffing through glass able to
detect attractiveness and not just a
really nice perfume powers too
it's a strange cross to bear this of
course is Jennifer Garner who doesn't
seem to grasp that love is blind
hey you know what the fill thought I'd
okay what a sec I didn't get your name I
didn't give it okay some people have no
compassion for the handicapped no see
love because he was Ben Affleck Oh
kissing some respect that's kind of a
handicap what do you want I just wanted
to give your name he follows her outside
to get her name but oh I can't even
explain it just watch wait a second
which time we could do like just we'll
start there
[Music]
okay so where do I begin with it first
of all I think she's making it pretty
clear she's not interested in your
stalker ass if she wanted she could call
the cops on you for being a creeper and
grabbing her but that it makes much more
sense to fight him which leads to the
second and most obvious problems if
she's fighting a blind guy she doesn't
know he has super senses and neither
does anyone else
so really what is there to gain if you
lose who got beaten by a blind guy
pretty pathetic but if you win Congrats
you piece of shit out of a fucking blind
guy how does anyone come out looking
good in this scenario my name is Weston
Agia no really what what's your name
that's so obviously can't be it
my name's elektra not you yes you should
meet my other parents with obvious real
name Anastasia Steele and Harvey
man-friend Jetson didn't so Murdoch an
electric nacho seemed to hit it off as
they go strolling together so we're not
a fight later my father family study
with a distance inside every year since
I was 5 years old
sounds like you wanted to send you to
some kind of a warrior
no not a victim which is clearly all I
am if I don't learn how to kick ass
he's very equal that way watch this oh
thank you
I didn't even wait how'd you do that
oh now you're asking how the fuck take
these stuff because I shit back there I
think Ray Charles do that I'm fuckin
Pepsi commercials watching screen a
paper trail one that can be traced will
not you give me Bulls on we're going to
introduce to our villains of the film
Michael Clarke Duncan as the kingpin and
Colin Farrell as bullseye and I swear
these guys are having the time of their
life whenever the camera is on them it's
like they know the movie is totally
fucking ridiculous so they're just gonna
have fun with their like any badger they
don't give a shit but he gets very well
for himself on the internet but don't
ask me how so I said oh because I swear
if Nicholas Cage was a drug he smoked
two bags worth oh can I get you anything
sorted man well penis we hope you
enjoyed this charming choking the old
ladies scene thank you for more
uncomfortable dives into the director
psyche those are Neville hunt down
another criminal preying on the weak
when it comes across an onlooker I'm not
a bad actress why is it just because I
dress like the devil everyone assumes
I'm the bad guy
[Music]
not the bad guy
no I'm not about bruit brooding yes
every early 2002 per euro has a moment
where he had to stare into the distance
to think yes but those other superheroes
usually has something to think about
he skated to because he was beating up a
bad guy how does that make him question
of them which I mean we shouldn't be a
brood on Jesus or do I am I see my job
what did you learn today my father
didn't want me to be addicted my mommy
you think no women learn martial arts
all the time right impassable clearly do
not be some strange reason why no a lot
of women just like men take it up just
because they want to take it up that's
crazy
there's got to be a reason why like a
father was trying to protect her Horo
bother was secretly a spy for about
always one of the fun or maybe her
mother played a part somehow wow that's
a good one yeah in between picking
flowers or not being good I'm just
saying a woman learning martial arts
isn't as rare as you think it is well
how else can we pretend she's unique
when she's clearly not I don't know I
just need a break from these early 2008
very well thanks Dean we draw closer to
the third acts you know what that means
sexy crash dr. Cox I'm so tortured he'll
never be here as kids
you
summer not really much trust tacos to
the root because he knows it's going to
rape and that'll allow him to see her
face better you are
[Music]
Wow
I'm sure this is the first time a
superhero who wears all red is kissing
his girlfriend in the rain but will be
remember better for it Plus puro duty
seemed to be calling what's wrong
oh it should have been about just us and
now it's about justice yeah don't worry
about it Hunter was nobody important who
was getting hi Jess
oh I'm sure things will turn up anyway
ah that's what I'm talking about
oh yeah quick sidenote early to
thousands of editing seem to really like
the style that somebody's what chic said
on the fast four button and then got up
just before the scene starts this is one
of the few additions I actually missed
from early 2000 films because as you can
tell they it gets the movie over faster
hello you are the blind lawyers for
those kids so he finally meets the
kingpin who wants to bring murder I can
do his business we can't represent you
why is it yes why is that mr. Murdock
because we only handle clients or
innocent uh-huh okay a blind man jumping
around and tight stopping crimes who can
see better than most people I can take
but a lawyer who only takes is in
clients I'm sorry if you totally cut the
suspension cord up this poly
and you I really want to see you again
what do you say we pull the fire alarm
it's at the sprinklers off but the
kingpin puts out a hit on her father and
of course well I use the one to pull it
off how many assassins stand out as much
as this guy judge
I mean for God's sake your destrun
during must be pretty easy that's catch
[Music]
can I adopt you
oh it's on my head so they point that
out climb Irish so electronic on tour
things of course the daredevil killed
her father and vows revenge meanwhile we
all giggle as one of the world's biggest
comic book geeks cameos in one of the
world's worst comic book movies as the
reporter realizes that the king used as
a weapon is also the Kay Murdock watch
with which is pretty fucking stupid when
you really think about it why the flying
hell would you walk around with that
it's not like Bruce Wayne driving in to
work with the battlefield somebody's
going to put two and two together you
know you've exceeded all my expectations
meanwhile the kingpin and bullseye me to
figure out what to do about daredevil me
made me make too much pride can kill a
man well that's just ridiculous
give me lecture oh my bad
he so evil even roses felt bad to him
what does he have for dinner corned beef
and cabbage patch kids
meanwhile not to you with the Libra
prepares for her revenge by taking on
the most dangerous obstacle she can
think of sandbag
[Music]
what the hell even dropping them is
there just a really confused servant who
is not sure why she's attacking the
flooding equipment in their chandelier
room madam why do you want me to paint a
cartoon devil on this one because he's
the one that killed my father
of course he is which we like to tour
some of the local rubber rooms in the
area by any chance so electron attack
daredevil outside the one weirdo who
dries his laundry at night for some
reason it wasn't me I didn't kill your
father what
nice read on that line garner I didn't
kill your father
yeah yeah you could really cause people
to crack without convicted n-not silly
that's at now it's just up all night
watching Game of Thrones hi okay
watching dead hi all right base motel
right all reports of recreation say oh
right I was watching Downton Abbey I
just have to know what Maggie's missing
the turn of the century social no harm
man shut up
she takes the shit off him but then
realizes the mistake she's made wait why
do I smell Jenna's fail cigarettes and
Lucky Charms
oh yeah he smears at Raths - this guy
could be a song lyric for the Grinch I
should get you medical attention but
yeah revenge is more important which
reminds me avenge me if I don't come
back come on well I can do that too oh
wait I forgot I suck you wouldn't be so
hot if you were a sandbag that's
annoying
that's annoying I'm not touching you I
don't get it I get so good at fighting a
blind guy you know now I'm putting the
pieces together we really suck yeah yeah
we do so she gets asked off as the
police tried to track him down
leading up to where we started speaking
a gettin started
that's what I plan to do it yeah John an
eccentric big I said rapid remarkability
mm slatina
new target ha ha ha ha let me guess
because you always hit your targets no I
just really like clearance prices ha ha
ha ha you know what we need to do you're
both going to defeat them so I'm going
to defeat him while she gets captured or
killed
what it's an early two-thousands thing
we make me look all tough but in the end
I got to be saved or Mort or you could
work together
looks like my class you're gonna catch
and things will kick then don't worry
I'm starting with my head I don't think
that's a good idea what that Wow oh ok
now I know exam or watch finally fight
no more in agony while he mode for the
camera
[Applause]
you do what you feel you're compelled to
do while I get back to the road Wow
bullseye tracks daredevil down to the
church and they partake in to Cullen
fuck you
Wow
I dodge bullets and Siamese stars and
yet somehow I miss that
the only thing consistent about my
powers is how inconsistent they are no
fear looks like I found something you're
afraid of the freeway Oh gran potatoes
oh bloody Gizem a touch a stigmata
because I don't know are we doing Jesus
symbolism in comic movies yet and he
wishes him a nice hmm I also have
accepted knock knock who's there
look do the Lord's work kill them kill
them fucking all sin the God's whole
hair I was raised in the Bronx Wesley
this is something you wouldn't
understand
yes I have to go 101 even though every
other murder I've committed has always
been done by the hands of others in fact
I even had other killed daredevil father
and only delivered the final punch it's
all about honor a very very very
inconsistent honor
daredevil tries to fight on before God
he sucks so he figures maybe the
sprinkler as well because yeah his
powers I could sense all these tiny
things apparently can't pick up a
300-pound seven foot giant for some
reason I'm thinking about this day I was
12 years old
uh I wonder if he knows he missed oh you
got me um dead I'm not the bad getting
oh no shit try telling that to the two
halves of the guy you let get run over
by a train that's not by the way I'm
totally not the bad guy you know what I
was saying
Oh where are we telling God the records
all about how you got beat by a blind
man like that walk it out yeah I know
and I'll be waiting
wait you're not killing the guy he just
said he'll get out to cause more chaos
because of the faulty justice system a
justice system you're a hard-on and then
you said until he gets out then it's not
you fucking idiot you keep thinking that
work I do not think it means what you
think it means
so the kingpin is put away until he's
let out again but it's okay
shop is dessert and we kept a later
where we see Murdock smelling someone
who looked like his dead girlfriend
makes about as much sense as the other
stuff when we found cut to the reporter
deciding whether or not to reveal their
Devils identity
Oh get it man this is probably
withholding evidence and I'm not sure
why I was writing about instead of going
to the police but I have little to no
part in this movie so why make an impact
now
oh thank fucking god these cliches are
so rarely done anymore
you could point to every comic book
movie before that this film was trying
to imitate from Batman's a spider-man's
of light but well the who needs at the
time offered something new this just
frozen what it heard worked in the paths
together without attaching any emotional
logic or character to it once in a while
you'll have something kind of neat like
the blind vision is kind of cool and
some of the fights work but they're way
too few and far between it was when the
old entires comic book cliches were
fading away and the new and inventive
ones were starting to take over and all
I can say is it was definitely for the
best
whole finding goods but what about our
current situation Buttercup oh don't
worry I know the one thing that can stop
every early 2000 hero or villain really
what's that
let's see your left nut oh and well the
bloody Sun came up we can't fight during
the day we look cool and I well I'll see
you in the sequel they'll never happen
I'm getting a sequel ah yeah that
wouldn't make any sense
so now what well reason is obvious I
jumped through the city looking off the
wall early 2000 song play only mean the
ones always sound like a southern take
it singing with a golf ball in his mouth
very one
I'll see you whatever justice is needed
quick I will have no fond memories of
you Inc until daddy
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
science